Okay.
It's usually Sam,
South African.
I've retained the accent.
And I think that must have some sort of
deep psychological reason.
Um,
and you know,
I think more and more for,
uh,
for people,
this is,
you know,
the reality of,
of life in a,
in a globalized world,
it's less and less,
I'm the exception.
And you know,
you could complain about it endlessly
and say you have no home.
And,
but it's also this incredible privilege
to move between countries.
And,
um,
so I try and remind myself of that
anytime,
you know,
I,
I'm about to fall into the trap of,
of self pity,
you know,
having family members.
My parents are now in Australia and my
sister's in London,
I'm in New York.
And it is a dilemma of,
you know,
how does a family ever then find its way
back to one another after so long living
apart.
But at the moment it's still feels more
like,
um,
good.